so one of the best things about hosting
this show is I get to hang out with
people that are so cool they actually
make me look cooler and one of those
guys is definitely hip-hop MC who wrote
this my mom the hip-hop MC schoolboy q
schoolboy q is amazing when I first met
him last summer when I went to the B et
hip-hop Awards you know like I do and a
few months later we had him on this show
and we just clicked he's amazing then
his debut album oxymoron debuted at
number one on the Billboard charts and
he became yeah he's awesome he became a
huge star so when I heard Q was
performing on Conan right next door I
couldn't pass up the opportunity to pop
in on my good friend in his green room
check it out thanks so much for having
me man you were by far my favorite guest
from the first run so actually I brought
you a gift
yeah the second time on the P Home Show
we got the first ever Oh Pete Home Show
lunchbox Wow is you're like a schoolboy
yeah yeah so I got a lunchbox and I
brought you an apple okay and you can
smoke weed out of it well I understand
your crew is gonna be here in like 20
minutes
yeah yeah how many people are in your
crew oh my god a lot of is in my boobs
all right I got my crew maybe you could
use one more mother yeah might as well
right right needle why help me on my
crew go saying somebody
what's the name of your crew you guys
have a name t-bird KP black hippies yo
did you consider Blimpie's I had some
ideas maybe you could call yourself
because it's like school boy you could
be like the after-school specials for
schools bill no no pals but it's with a
Z so you know it's hip-hop
pounds I thought it would be fun like I
brought my own Schoolboy Q hat oh okay
got your low both you know is this
alright damn you probably get a bigger
one that you rap about titties a lot
yeah I like them in the air you know
what I'm saying
you like him in the open air do you like
titties or a s'more I like a s'more it's
like the downstairs titties ass so fat
you can see it from the front that's him
that's mos def yeah yeah of course
you know most yeah I'm not most of you
need to know big I know most and quali
I know I'm like Bilbo Baggins I get no
[ __ ]
now that is nothing so this is your
green room isn't every room you're in a
green room oh yeah that was a girl right
I wouldn't even hold cards like I'd be
having them up like this yeah you also
have some swag when you flip to do shoot
right if I'm in your honor I'd like one
thing
like let's say you've got begin to have
your show so you're going off the back
right and going to your limo or like
maybe like a stretch Benz yeah and you
get in with your friends you know I'm
still right when I'm in riding mode the
homies are there a leather chair yeah
yeah and then trash like this this yappy
blonde girl Trish the typical white girl
is it all up in your business and you
know the move like that's when I would
go and I go step off Trish
let me ask you are you looking for maybe
kind of like an awkward
doughy guy tall that could be in your
entourage yeah you you trying to come
through that's what I'm say
what are we eating are we eating a
Organic plant-based diet yeah you are
that we you I don't know why I'm having
the best